how did an obscure competition series on
a defunct Network grow into a ratings
Juggernaut for NBC for American Ninja
Warrior the road to popularity was a
true obstacle course
early seasons of American Ninja Warrior
were very different it was initially
known as American Ninja challenge a
video submission Series in which
contestants submitted videos of
themselves on ninja obstacles the
ultimate goal of that early version of
the series was to compete on the
Japanese game show Sasuke in those first
few seasons contestants competed in one
city qualifying course in Venice Beach
the top 30 moved on to the city finals
where they entered a boot camp that
whittled them down to just 10 Ninja
finalists from there the 10 Ninja
finalists traveled to Japan to compete
on Sasuke although the format was
different there were still some familiar
ninjas competing including James McGrath
Brent Stevenson and Flip Rodriguez
American Ninja Warrior didn't get its
start on NBC the show started out on G4
TV also known as G4 a network within the
company's cable group that channel
doesn't exist anymore but it provided a
home for American Ninja Warrior for its
first three increasingly popular Seasons
according to host Matt Eiseman G4 went
to NBC during the third season and
offered to allowed them to air the
finale for free in an interview with GQ
Eismann recalled exact same just aired
on NBC to tell people G4 exists so the
show swapped networks and with little to
no promotion the mostly unheard of
obstacle course series ended up winning
the ratings for the night this led to
American Ninja Warriors permanent
relocation in season four American Ninja
Warrior fans know that show co-host Matt
Eisman is the man responsible for the
signature drawn out pronunciation of the
show's title
many don't realize that he had quite an
interesting life before taking his place
at the podium before becoming a TV
personality Eisman graduated with honors
from Princeton University and earned his
medical degree at the Columbia College
of Physicians and surgeons he did his
residency in Internal Medicine at the
University of Colorado and was a
practicing doctor before he decided to
leave the medical world and take a shot
at his true passion comedy even as I was
doing medical school I was doing some
stand-up comedy and initially I didn't
think it was going to end up being my
career as a comedian he performed at the
2002 Salt Lake City Winter Olympics and
traveled the world with the Uso before
joining American Ninja Warrior in its
second season it may sound like the
hosts of American Ninja Warrior are
right there in the moment however the
way the course is set up makes it so
that they can't always see the first few
obstacles as Eiseman told reality
blurred the hosts watch on monitors this
gives them close-up views of the
obstacles they can see while allowing
the hosts to provide more accurate
commentary about about my new details
like hand placements and grips Eisman
told the outlet on a typical course we
usually can't see the first or second
obstacle we can then see most of them up
to the Warped wall and then we'll have
monitors in front of us for the
obstructed obstacles and close-ups he
said we're watching the monitor trying
to get a better sense of it particularly
on stuff where it's hand placement
where's their grip going well usually we
can see most of the course American
Ninja Warrior held its first celebrity
competition as part of NBC's Red Nose
Day in 2017 allowing the likes of
Aerostar Stephen Amell and Dancing with
the Stars dancer Derek Huff to take on
the course NBC then brought the special
back in 2018 with co-host Akbar kajibila
Mila even joining in on the runs for
charity this is special for me to be
able to run this red nose course this is
for a good cause other stars who've
taken on the American Ninja Warrior
course throughout the years include
Survivor contestants Olympians and
professional athletes from Globetrotters
to MMA fighters repeat appearances have
included race car driver Jade Beaufort
and former NFL player Andrew East one of
the most persistent celebrity
competitors is Olympic silver medalist
gymnast Jonathan Horton who competed in
three separate Seasons between 2014 and
2021. despite his Valiant efforts though
he's never made it to the National
Finals in Las Vegas
Jesse Graf has doubled for a superhero
on TV and she's basically a real life
superhero too grapp who worked as a
stunt double on multiple episodes of The
CW Supergirl made history on the course
in the summer of 2016 when she became
the first woman to complete stage one in
Las Vegas a veteran of several of the
show's Seasons Raph is popped up as a
stuntwoman and a whole bunch of your
favorite TV shows and movies including
Live Free or Die Hard bridesmaids and
Transformers Dark of the Moon in 2020
she had the privilege of appearing in
Wonder Woman 1984 as both an Amazonian
Warrior and stunt double for Wonder
Woman herself Gal Gadot the stuntwoman
is also well known for her real-life
staging of the famous Family Guy chicken
fight which has over 1.9 million views
on YouTube
chicken
gave me a bad Koopa
it seems like a no-brainer that quite a
lot of planning and work goes into
setting up the elaborate obstacles of
American Ninja Warrior but it's
interesting to see just how deep the
process goes the whole course is the
size of a football field while Las
Vegas's Mount Midoriyama is the size of
four football fields so that's a lot of
real estate to fill up with new
challenges producer Brian Richardson
said planning the obstacles takes months
of brainstorming with some ideas
starting as something someone sketched
on a napkin
from there they figure out the course on
paper before building a prototype and
testing it in a warehouse if it passes
it makes it to the course but the
testing isn't done yet even more people
test the course to make sure the
difficulty is at the right level
apparently producers have a set goal of
around 20 percent of contestants
finishing the city qualifiers meaning
that they repeatedly Test new obstacles
until they find about 24 to include
contestants don't know which obstacles
they'll face going in and they're not
allowed to try out the course before
their official run so it's on them to
figure out in the moment how to keep up
with whatever producers throw at them
the obstacles are also ordered in a
certain way something frequent observers
of the show May notice according to the
people responsible for Designing the
challenges this is done on purpose to
provide some structure the first
obstacle is always some variation of the
steps usually four paths the contestants
can either run or jump across the second
obstacle is a not too hard upper body
challenge co-executive producer Anthony
storm told Men's Journal almost everyone
can physically get past the second
obstacle but if you're nervous you're
probably going to fail it the other
obstacles tend to focus on skills like
balance upper body strength and speed
the third obstacle for instance is
usually balance based while the fifth
once again focuses on upper body
strength the qualifying course always
ends with the Warped wall while the
salmon ladder always places eighth when
moving on to the city finals up until
season five American Ninja Warrior
contestants competed during the day
since then however filming has happened
at night tapings in each City begin
around 8pm and go into the wee hours of
the morning with some contestants doing
their runs around 3 or 4 am even
contestants who run earlier in the night
can stick around that late if they're
waiting to find out whether they made it
into the top 30 or 15. especially those
who are on the edge this is obviously
quite taxing on contestants adding a
whole new layer of difficulty to an
already grueling show being a great
athlete doesn't guarantee you a spot on
American Ninja Warrior while the show
obviously puts quite a lot of effort in
defining contestants who are able to
compete there are a lot of other factors
that go into casting to apply to be on
American Ninja Warrior contestants have
to submit a long online questionnaire as
well as a video of themselves the video
is where contestants have to really let
their personality shine in the video
contestants have to convince the casting
directors that they won't just be able
to complete the course but that they'll
also be fun to watch as with most
reality shows the ninja casting
directors are looking for contestants
with interesting stories who will
inspire viewers both on and off the
course
Jeff Britton became the first man to
reach the top of stage four in Vegas in
season 7 of American Ninja Warrior but
he didn't end up with the one million
dollar prize instead that went to Isaac
caldiero the second man to finish
caldiero topped the rope in just under
four seconds less than Britain it's like
a dream right now the fact that Britain
walked away empty-handed caused a lot of
upset among American Ninja Warrior fans
seeing as Britain finished every single
course while caldero did not caldiero
failed in the second to last Obstacle of
the Kansas City finals but still
qualified to move on to Las Vegas due to
his fast time Britain took the results
in stride for the most part but many
fans did not some fans even set up a
GoFundMe account to give Britain his 1
million dollars while it didn't come
anywhere near reaching that lofty goal
the GoFundMe account did raise fourteen
thousand dollars since the controversy
the show has made several adjustments to
its formula in season 8 for example the
rules were changed so that multiple
finishers of stage 4 would split the top
prize then in season 10 the show
introduced the 100 000 prize for Last
Ninja standing the last ninja standing
is the competitor who goes the furthest
the fastest regardless of whether all
the stages are completed many ninjas
have to quit their day jobs if they want
to get serious about competing because
being an elite level ninja is basically
like being a pro athlete ninjas are
finding new ways to make a living based
on their athleticism this includes doing
commercials and making appearances at
gems and other events a high percentage
of ninjas also own their own gems
however some ninjas are still pushing
for more with many believing that the
future of the sport may eventually lead
as far as the Olympics for now however
the main concern is compensation for
athletes while the show has the one
million dollar prize early Seasons
didn't offer much else it wasn't until
after the season 7 controversy that the
show instituted the 100 000 prize for
Last Ninja standing and small monetary
prizes for top city finals finishers
however the show will have to continue
to evolve and update its rules for
compensation and sponsorships in order
to keep the athletes coming back
American Ninja Warrior has gotten a lot
more popular and so have Ninja gems once
a specialty business these gems let
people train using the same types of
obstacles and techniques they see in the
show The Gems began to pop up all over
the country and have become a cottage
industry all their own the increasing
trend of ninja gyms has resulted in more
applications for the show which saw 50
000 people apply for season seven up
from just five thousand for season six
this has also resulted in competitors
like Josh Levin and Daniel Gill both
trained for years at ninja gyms while
waiting until they were old enough to
get on the show so if you've ever wanted
to take a shot at the course look around
for your nearest ninja Gem and start
practicing the success of American Ninja
Warrior has led to quite a few spin-offs
including specials like celebrity
American Ninja Warrior family Ninja
Warrior and us say versus the world
there have also been full-fledged shows
like team Ninja Warrior and American
Ninja Warrior Junior the latter of which
allowed kids ages 9 to 14 a chance to
compete there are also similar
competitions like Spartan Ultimate Team
Challenge this show brought in teams of
athletes for a difficult race with four
people serving under an elite Captain
it's Spartan Ultimate Team Challenge was
often paired with American Ninja Warrior
on NBC's summer schedule providing a
whole night of athletic fun American
Ninja Warrior has also spawned a few
copycats most notably Netflix's ultimate
Beastmaster in which contestants run an
obstacle course called The Beast the
show uses a very similar format to Ninja
Warrior and features similarly difficult
types of obstacles however unlike
American Ninja Warrior Beastmaster
always crowns a winner in the end Matt
eiseman's cohort in the American Ninja
Warrior commentators box is former NFL
linebacker Akbar bajibi emila the
transition from professional athlete to
sports analyst is a common one but this
Los Angeles Native Son of Nigerian
immigrants adds a boisterous enthusiasm
that makes him a joy to watch
furthermore his quick analysis of ninjas
runs on the American Ninja Warrior
course provides excellent Insight one
reason for that insight and enthusiasm
might be that baja bi amila himself once
appeared as a reality contestant
Expedition impossible aired in 2011 on
ABC and featured 13 teams of three in a
format very similar to The Amazing Race
on the show teams traveled together to
various checkpoints completed challenges
and race to the end prior to hosting
American Ninja Warrior Baja bi amila
worked for NFL Network and now he splits
his ninja time as co-host of the talk on
CBS in addition he holds a certificate
from the Wharton School of Business and
became a published author in 2019 with
his motivational book everyone can be a
ninja several women worked as sideline
reporters for American Ninja Warrior
over the years in 2019 however Zuri Hall
joined the team and broke the malt Hall
worked in local TV news before turning
her talents to hosting in a variety of
venues from the NBA to the Thanksgiving
Day Parade she went on to work for e in
several capacities in addition to MTV
VH1 bet and others now she reports for
Access Hollywood and co-hosts all access
in addition to where American Ninja
Warrior duties Paul earned a full
academic scholarship to the Ohio State
University for her entire four-year
tenure and now holds a degree in
strategic communication she also minored
in theater and even studied with the
famed improv group Upright Citizens
Brigade Paul uses her celebrity to
support black women racial Justice and
underprivileged communities that said
her advocacy is a feature American Ninja
Warrior Embraces unlike most competition
reality shows American Ninja Warrior is
a huge supporter of charitable work with
contestants often wearing their causes
on their sleeves Paul loves being a part
of the American Ninja Warrior community
and its persistent emphasis on
conquering obstacles in life as well as
on the course
when five foot tall Casey Catanzaro
reached the top of the Warped wall in
2014 she made history as the first woman
ever to complete a qualifying course on
American Ninja Warrior when she
completed the Dallas city finals course
a few weeks later a movement was born it
was known as the Casey effect and it
culminated in hundreds of women taking
up the sport and applying to compete on
the show Kat and zaro opened the door to
men and women being held to equal
standards at least in the network ninja
obstacle course competition series Elite
athlete Jesse Graf gym owner Jesse flex
labrec and personal trainer Michelle
warnke fought to be higher in the
rankings than some of the most highly
rated men to have been on the show now
Kat and zaro competes in a whole new
Arena as part of World Wrestling
Entertainment as a WWE wrestler she
paired with Kaden Carter as a tag team
together they not only won the
championship but retained it for a
record-breaking 186 days wrestling is a
big change from Ninja courses but no
matter what cadenzaro does from now on
She'll always be the person who set a
new standard for women in American Ninja
Warrior I want to go out the best that I
can and you know I want to continue to
make people proud couples meeting on
reality television is not a new
phenomenon but when they meet on
American Ninja Warrior the bonds seem a
little stronger take James the Beast
McGrath and Alyssa beard the couple met
while competing on the show together six
years later McGrath popped the question
following his successful completion of
the qualifying course the moment was
poignant sweet and completely
inspirational then there's Chris to
Genji and Jesse Flex lebreck their
relationship also started as a result of
the show and it's grown in front of the
audience's eyes throughout the years the
two are loving and supportive of one
another but also highly competitive the
Genji and lebreck are so evenly matched
that they often fall at the same
obstacle finish the wall together and
run step for step when competing head to
head in 2023 an another Ninja Love Story
came to light when the show revealed
that Caitlin Bergstrom and David Wright
were married in September 2022. the
couple initially met at the Las Vegas
finals in 2019. Caitlyn's ninja brother
Caleb is also married to a fellow ninja
competitor Ashley and the foursome make
training and competing together a family
affair early seasons of American Ninja
Warrior were known for their days-long
walk-on lines where contestant hopefuls
would Camp outside just for the chance
to compete stars like Kevin Bull had
Unforgettable runs after coming on as
walk-on contestants moreover regular
competitor Dave Kavanaugh is known as
king of the Walk-Ons because he made it
to the show through that process for
five straight seasons unfortunately the
process was cumbersome and often
required prospective ninjas to take
weeks off of work for only a slim chance
to compete for season 11 therefore the
process was changed instead of camping
at taping locations contestants could
enter themselves on a lottery at one of
the qualifying cities the lottery
process was incredibly simple consisting
of no more than 20 names being selected
from the entrance those 20 entrants were
the successful Walk-Ons for that City
and anyone who didn't get on the show
there could apply at one of the other
locations when American Ninja Warrior
first landed on TV screens contestants
had to be at least 21 to compete for 12
Seasons this was the case
unsurprisingly those in their early 20s
were some of the strongest and fastest
competitors however the real inspiration
came from a lot of the older contestants
ninja has always been a sport that
allows people of all ages to try their
hands at the obstacles in 2018 however
the age limit was lowered to 19 and the
focus of the show began to Pivot to the
younger Ninja America
America for season 13 the age limit was
lowered again and teens as young as 15
were invited to compete on the elaborate
obstacle course obviously youth has
always been a focus of television in
general but fans were evenly split on
whether the lowered limit was a good
idea or not many believe they're younger
more flexible bodies would hold an
unfair Advantage others thought their
lack of experience would be a
disadvantage however the great success
of some of these younger competitors
particularly Kaden lebsack means the
change is here to stay of the many
American Ninja Warrior Superstars some
of the most successful have had a
previous history of excelling in other
sports athletes who have trained to
control their body movements in midair
such as gymnasts and pole vaulters seem
to hold a certain Edge rock climbers
with their incredible grip strength
strategic problem solving and ability to
Pace themselves for long climbs have
also landed among the elite competitors
the Show's first winners for example
were rock climbers Jeff Britton and
Isaac caldiero whose upper body strength
grip strength and stamina serve them
extremely well in the courses some of
those who've attempted stage four like
call the arrow and Josh Levin are
professional rock climbers while one of
them Travis Rosen is a former gymnast
furthermore some of the best women to
compete on American Ninja Warrior have
also leveraged skills from these same
areas Jesse Graf is famously a former
record-setting pole vaulter while Casey
Catanzaro and Barkley Stockett were both
gymnasts meanwhile rock climber Megan
Martin boasts pole vaulting competitive
climbing and Gymnastic skills all of
which she utilized to become the first
women's champion in 2021 in season 8
American Ninja Warrior announced its
obstacle design challenge since then 29
obstacles to appear across the stages
have been designed by fans and fellow
ninjas four of them were designed by the
same guy Kevin the maker Carbone in
season 9 carbon became the first
designer to compete on his own invention
successfully completing the wing nuts
obstacle in Daytona Beach got to the
course after three weeks of waiting and
I look up and there's the Wingnut in
fact Carbone was so successful at
creating new obstacles that it became
his profession Carbone wasn't the only
competitor to design new hurdles for the
athletes to face fellow ninjas Kevin
brecky Christian Yost and Brett Sims
have also submitted obstacles that
appeared on the show however it doesn't
require a ninja to design a good
obstacle in season 14 tetherball
premiered having been designed by Stacy
Harris while the obstacle design
challenge was not announced for season
15 new fan design obstacles are still
premiering on ninja courses on episode 3
contestants had to try to navigate the
puzzling upper body obstacle the cubes
the Cube's obstacle was designed by a 10
year old fan from Ithaca New York named
Grace proving good ideas are ageless
dubbed the real life Ninja Drew dreschel
was an American Ninja Warrior Fina a
free runner and gym owner dressel had
competed on the show every year since
season four he was known for Fast Times
and great finesse and was easily one of
the show's favorite personalities after
years of competing vreschl finally won
the distinction of Last Ninja standing
in season 10 and was a grand prize
winner in season 11. in 2020 however
news broke that dressel had been
arrested on various charges of illegal
sexual contact with the minor the
charges were supported by several
explicit pictures in dressel's
possession of the minor in question
American Ninja Warrior wasted no time in
responding to the charges permanently
severing all ties with dressel and
editing him out of episodes that it yet
to air in a statement quoted by NBC News
a spokesperson for the show said we will
not let the actions of one contestant
tarnish the hard work and amazing
stories of so many on June 1st 2023 Drew
drechschel entered into a plea deal for
which he is yet to be sentenced the deal
encompassed pleading guilty to two
charges that could result in up to 60
years in prison and would require
registration as a sex offender threshold
sentencing is set for October 24th 2023.
[Music]